pour caroline de camaret et à versailles
pour france 24 vous suivait ce conseil
pour nous caroline les 27 devaient donc
trouver des plants une réponse
économique et militaire apportée à
l'ukraine qu'est ce qui en est ressorti
en ce deuxième jour de réunion
alors emmanuel macron voulait d'ailleurs
un sursaut de l'union européenne et il
n'est pas il n'est pas complètement déçu
aujourd'hui parce que c'est vrai que
l'union européenne a fini par comprendre
qu'elle ne pouvait pas demeurer un nain
géopolitique est un géant économique
mais qu'elle devait aussi se hisser au
titre de géant géopolitique et pour cela
et bien face à une guerre à lui en
ukraine c'est à dire sur territoire
européen elle aligne les milliards
peut-être un milliard donc c'est ce qu'a
demandé en tout cas le chef de la
diplomatie européenne pour envoyer des
armes aux ukrainiens donc les aider très
concrètement dans leur combat parce que
l'union européenne ne doit pas non plus
être complètement dépendante de la vie
des américains et de leur puissance à
l'otan on a bien vu qu'il y avait eu un
nombre et godillots des deux côtés de
l'atlantique entre les polonais qui
voulait envoyer leurs mig leurs avions
mig 29 aux ukrainiens et les américains
qui étaient très prudents qu'ils
pensaient que c'était en quelque sorte
une provocation mais en attendant les
européens veulent pouvoir avoir une
propre boussole stratégique et une
indépendance pour ce qui est de penser
les conflits à venir tout cela le
président français le martèle depuis son
entrée au pouvoir en 2017 et même s'il a
une relation ici même privilégié avec
les admire poutine puisque à versailles
en 2017 il l'a rencontré et premier chef
d'état qui venaient en grande pompe à
versailles après l'élection d' emmanuel
macron il continue à dialoguer avec lui
mais tout le monde emmanuel makoun et
les autres ont pris la mesure finalement
de la nécessité de renforcer une défense
européenne avoir une autonomie
stratégique sur tous les moyens et on
l'a dit économique également
énergétique est aussi alimentaire et
puis véritablement prendre à bras le
corps cette question d'une flanc est
menacée par la puissance russe dans les
européens disposent et caroline à
fournir des armes légères à l'ukraine à
un financement d'un milliard d'euros a
même été annoncée les jeux cités le
président ukrainien qui appelle les
européens à en faire beaucoup plus il
faut comprendre par là que ce refus
d'embargo par exemple sur le gaz russe
ne le compte entamer les européens sont
dépendants cette énergie
tout à fait c'est vrai que le président
et l'ins qui voulait dans un premier
temps une adhésion accélérée à l'union
européenne qui lui a été refusée il
pensait qu'il est l'entrée dans un club
à la fois souhaitable est très
protecteur mais ça n'est pas possible ce
n'est pas prévu par les traités ça n'est
pas souhaitable non plus pour ne pas
provoquer vladimir poutine deuxième
chose il ya la question de la dépendance
bien réelle cette fois au gaz russe de
40% alors pour pour la france c'est
moins sensible c'est à peine 17% mais
pour certains pays comme la lettonie ou
encore la république tchèque la finlande
c'est 100% de dépendance au gaz russe il
n'est pas possible du jour au lendemain
d'abandonner par un embargo sur le gaz
et le pétrole comme le font les
américains d' abandonner et bien tous
ces pipelines qui relie la russie à
l'union européenne pour la fournir en
gaz en tout cas on va essayer de s'en
débarrasser au deux tiers d'ici le
prochain hiver c'est ce qu'a dit la
présidente de la commission européenne
est totalement d'ici cinq ans donc ce
sera une démarche progressive c'est
dommage pense évidemment les ukrainiens
qui voit bien que cet embargo sur le gaz
et le pétrole c'était la cerise sur le
gâteau qui aurait fait peut être craquer
vladimir poutine et peut-être qu'il
aurait
bloqué ainsi terminé sa guerre et que ça
n'est pas possible en tout état de cause
du côté européen
mais en revanche les européens
progressivement monte vers des sanctions
de plus en plus pénalisant pour la
russie et qui commencent à porter leurs
fruits